Film Courage: We had a question come in from
our viewer Ernesto Caro and Ernesto writes “My
biggest curiosity is the pacing of the story.
I'm a screenwriter and I love comics but I
couldn't even imagine how to pace a comic book
in regard to dialogue versus action per page?”
Stephen L. Stern, Comic Book Author/President of
Storyboard Graphic Novels: Okay, now in order for
me to answer this question I need to talk a little
bit about this company I established 10 years ago,
actually in 2011 so back in 2011 it was quite
clear to me that there was a real nexus between
graphic novels and comics. On the one hand and
film and animation on the other by which I mean
to say more and more movies were being based
on comic books and graphic novels for example
most people are familiar with the movie Road
to Perdition what most people don't know is
that started its life as a graphic novel it was
written by well-known mystery novelist Max Allen
Collins and it was taken to Hollywood by a fellow
named Ken F. Levin who is also the publisher and
founder of 1First Comics that published is Zen
[Zen Intergalactic Ninja] okay and so I knew that
there was a real connection between movies and
comic books and so I came up with this concept
of a company that is called Storyboard Graphic
Novels and it essentially says to screenwriters
but also producers directors and actors give us
your screenplay and we'll turn it into a graphic
novel or a comic book series and this brings up
the answer to your viewers question what happens
is this okay after we sign a contract and we
were on board with a screenwriter who say has
a 100 page screenplay okay what happens is I
read the screenplay and I start thinking about
an appropriate artist for the genre of the book is
superhero is it a romcom is it horror is it sci-fi
right at the same time I'm doing that I personally
write the adaptation the graphic novel adaptation
many of my fellow writers in the industry have
asked me hey Steve could I write some of these
adaptations for you thus far I've personally
written every adaptation which is over 80 of
them since 2011 it's probably closer to 100 now
the reason I do that is I always invoke this quote
from Liam in the movie Taken. Do you remember
when he said I have a particular set of skills?
Well I do, I have a particular set of skills.
I know how to take a movie script and convert
it into a graphic novel script and some of the
things that relate to that are how there's a page
of a screenplay is equivalent to a minute on the
screen well a page of a screenplay is equivalent
to a page and a third in a graphic novel. In
other words it takes more than a one page of
a screenplay to get it into a graphic novel.
It's going to be like a page in a third and
this algorithm if you want to call it has proved
correct for like dozens and dozens of books. So I
came up with that algorithm and it works right but
in terms of the facing and what your viewer asked,
you have to know how to take a screenplay which
is written for the fluid medium of film and turn
it into a script for the static medium of a
comic book or graphic novel because a book is
static. It's panel after panel after panel after
panel. It's called sequential art okay and this
is something because I've done it so frequently
I know how to do it and part and parcel of that
is also knowing things like how to keep a page
cinematic by not only not overburdening it with
too many panels but just as important is how
many words you can put on a page how many word
balloons maximum can go in a panel so these
are all like formulas if you will to ensure
that the story moves along at the right pace is
still cinematic looking and isn't overburdened
by text which is word balloons and captions
so again to explain how to do this would be
tantamount to explaining how to write a movie
script right and that's something that we don't
have enough time to discuss here oh sure but
I'm curious as a rule how many word balloons
are considered sort of the standard acceptable
per panel two or three but it all depends how
many words are in each balloon when you get into
like a soliloquy or a monologue you may have to
divide up what the character is saying into like
four panels because there's also like a maximum
number of words you can put in a balloon which
is like 12 if you really must know right these
are all formulas that I've worked out right and
yeah so pacing characters cinematic nature how
much dialogue to put in it's it's an art and
a science that's great information thank you
I'm going to start really like noticing that I
think I'll start when I look at comics I'm going
to really take notice of of because maybe to to
the to the amateur pointing to myself I wouldn't
totally notice if it's too clutter like I'll
just notice something's off but ion know why
yeah how many written pages is a comic book is
there a standard well I mean comic books today
typically are 20 pages of story there's a the
20 page stories there's also a new movement to
have thicker comics like almost double-sized
like 40 page books so today a book is either
maybe around 20 pages or around 40 pages but
but when you say written a script that I will
write for a comic it's pretty much like one for
one a 20 page comic might take about 20 pages
of script how long does it take you to write a
comic book the answer to that is as long as it
takes there's no strict answer sometimes you can
get up in the morning your subconscious has been
working you sit down at the computer and within
an hour or two you've got the script then again
you can have some writer block or some issues you
can't quite resolve that quickly and it could take
a month again there's really no definitive answer
to that do you find personally though that you're
better in the morning or maybe a certain time in
the afternoon well I'm not a morning person okay
and I'm kind of erratic to be honest with with
you because I've been in business for myself
for so long I have to set my own schedule and
as a result if there's a deadline coming up
I'll get it done because I have no option so the
answer unfortunately is there's no easy answer.